So welcome to lecture number three of
the course. Um let's
okay so let me remind you of the key aim
of the course which is that we want to
learn physics modeled by PTE from data
using neural networks. So these are the
four sort of key terms and we already in
the last lecture did a proper very short
introduction to neuronet networks. We
know that these are essentially maps. So
I don't remember the notation that we
used but let's say that these are maps
ft here which take u vector input and go
to a vector output. So if you have any
element y belongs to y f theta of y
equals to z. Right? So this is the basic
mathematical operation. So theta are the
sort of weights and biases.
Weights biases.
So these are also called the training
parameters.
And the idea is that we always have a
ground truth.
which is given by f which is a map from
y to z right and we have data.
So the data is in the form of
y i
f of y i
plus some epsilon i
i i from 1 to capital n. Right? So this
is the basic construction and the idea
is that you minimize. So we can write it
here. You minimize um
the so-called loss function L of theta
which can be f okay should be more
clear. Let's do it like this. So sum
over i of
f yi minus f theta of not yi.
This we can call as Z I maybe that's the
simplest way to do it. Then I can
erase it a little
then write Z I minus F theta
to the power P for some P right so this
is the object that we want to minimize
so theta star is equal to the minimum
arg min of L of theta
so this is uh machine learning in a
nutshell right so you have some ground
truth which is given by this If you have
data which is given by these data pairs
they're drawn iid but need not
necessarily be but ideally iid from some
distribution and then you have this
parametric maps f of theta and you
minimize this loss function by using
gradient descent right so this is the
next element gradient descent
gradient descent so that's what it is
and we are going to use this sort of
construction this um framework a
pipeline in order to learn PDS or learn
solutions of PDS and so on. But there is
immediately a barrier to that. So let us
try to explain what that is. So I'm just
reminding you to the heat equation,
right? So this is the arguably the
simplest PD that you can think which
represents spatial temporal variation.
So what does the heat equation do? So
you have ut= to uxx. This is your um
equation. You have some initial
conditions and you have some boundary
conditions. Right? So in other words in
the spatial temporal domain. So you have
here is the initial conditions. So this
is initial.
These are the boundaries boundary
boundary
and what you need to find out is the
solution in the rest of the domain
subject to the equation which is given
by this guy here. So that's that's
essentially what we have right. So it
turns out that when you apply a
numerical method now in principle for
this simple equation I can even write
down some analytical or semi analytical
solution using the 4A series maybe some
of you know how to do that but in
general in the very first lecture I told
you that we could use a finite
difference method I'm not going to
recapitulate what the finite difference
method is it is written here and that
provides me a very good approximation
right and the interesting thing about
the finite difference scheme is that and
of any numerical method is that it does
not no data is used. No data
right because what does data mean in
this context? Data would mean that
remember so what is the ground truth? So
if you remember the framework I need a
ground truth right. So what will be the
ground truth? The ground truth would be
the solution operator u right which is a
mapping from your domain and time to
scala values. So this is the temperature
that varies as a function of space and
time. And so if you look at this
framework, the framework that we just
described in the last lecture for which
you did tutorials uh two tutorials, the
point that you immediately see is that
by to adapt that to sort of put it in
that setting immediately there's a
problem because you need some samples of
the ground truth right so if you so data
in this case would be essentially
u at some xi ti for some points Okay,
but this is what we don't have, right?
So it is uh we we need to solve this
problem in order to find the solution at
different points. But machine learning
on the other hand requires data. It
says, okay, give me data at some points
and then maybe I can predict the
solution at other points. But to begin
with, we only have information about the
initial conditions. This is given to us.
We only have information about the
boundary conditions and all that we know
is the physical law that the system
satisfies which is the heat equation UT=
UXX. So to apply this setting that is
there to this setting that we need the
sort of setup that we need there's
immediately an issue right and the issue
is given by the fact that there is no a
priority data. So is that clear? So to
solve the equation we we just need the
initial and boundary conditions. A
finite difference scheme can do that.
But to use machine learning at least in
the form that I just described to you,
we need to find values of the solution
in the interior of the domain which we
don't have necessarily access to. You'll
see that this can be changed in the
future but at the moment we don't have
access to that. So there is this
dichotomy. There is this discrepancy
between what the pipeline gives us and
what we need. Right? Is there any issue
about that? Does anyone have a question?
Is the issue clear? Okay, good. So this
is the sort of the fundamental question
that there is no data or sometimes in
machine learning technology or
terminology rather some people call it
as no label data
because essentially machine learning is
about dogs and cats right it's by seeing
an image and saying this is a dog seeing
another image and saying this is a cat
taking lots of dogs and cats and making
the system say that okay the next image
that you have whether it's a dog or a
cat that's that's machine learning in a
nutshell
But now we are in a different situation
altogether that in principle we don't
have the dogs and cats. We don't we we
look at a point we don't have any
information whether that is a dog or a
cat or what is the value of the function
at that point. So this tells us that
there is a sort of a discrepancy there's
a chasm between what the standard
machine learning pipeline gives us which
is very data dependent data heavy and
the task at hand right which we for
instance can solve with the finite
difference method very very easily. So
what do we do in that case right? So
this is the question. So essentially the
first question that we can answer is
what I have written down here. So can
neural networks this is our main
objective. Can they be used to solve PTE
without any data? Right? So this is sort
of the because uh we we know that with
traditional numerical methods we can we
can do that. So in principle this is
true. In principle,
we know that given any function, given
any measurable function, this is what I
told you about universal approximation
measurable function
U. So the U which is a solution of the
heat equation of course is not just
measurable, it's a smooth function. So U
is a nice function. So given any
function there exists a neural network n
you can also say deep neural network u
theta such that u minus u theta is as
close as we want right so this is always
there so there is a neural network out
there where which is going to
approximate the solution of the heat
equation for instance or some other pd
but the question is uh how am I going to
find this optimum right where how are
you theta theta star perhaps so how am I
going to find how to find
theta
u theta star or theta star just from the
equation from the pd because now we
don't have data if you have data then we
can just use the pipeline that we had we
had some measurements we know that uh we
can use this measurements and then we
can solve the problem but when you don't
have that data what do you do right so
that turns out that there are some
solutions even to this problem which a
priority seems to be not falling into
the traditional framework of machine
learning and this is what are called
physics informed neural networks right
so as I said in the course one of the
learning objectives is to understand
something about physics informed neural
networks so physics informed neural
networks are neural networks which can
so these are neural networks which can
solve PTE without any data okay so this
is the sort of the framework they're
still neural networks but what we have
to do now is to use the PTE and initial
boundary conditions in order to make the
neural network approximate to okay so at
least the rationale is very very clear
that we we have this issue we don't have
uh data or don't have label data if you
want to call it and then we can use some
technology or some algorithm to be able
to do that and this is given by physics
informative networks they've been around
actually for a long time the first paper
was in the 19 that's not mine I
So the first paper was around in the
1990s by these gentlemen but it was
really developed by a guy called Laris
who is from Greece in the mid 1990s. So
Laris is the one who sort of popularized
or invented how to use neuronet
networks. So remember that in the 1990s
almost no one knew about neural networks
in general. They were just getting
artificial neuronet networks. They're
just getting started. So he did that. No
one took his work seriously. Even when I
was a master student, I saw those papers
but I never took them seriously. No one
did till deep learning revolution
started right. So once the deep learning
revolution started people realized that
oh now you can train neuronet networks
you can do something useful with them.
So this was to the credit of these three
gentlemen particularly carneakis from
Brown University that he took these
methods he simplified them and then
around 2017 is when physics and he gave
the name
did not call it as physics informal
networks uh but George Kanyakis called
them as physics informal networks and
today this is a very active area and
there are at least 10,000 papers maybe
many more so it's a very easy way but
what are these physics disinformal
networks. So in today's lecture and in
the next lecture we will at least part
of the next lecture we are going to
study them or we are going to understand
what they are and I think the next two
tutorials are also on physics and
permanent networks. So you'll get quite
a bit of coverage of this topic. Very
interesting, right? How can you use
neuronet networks without any data? It
turns out that the idea is uh in
principle remember we can do it. There
always exists a neural network which is
going to approximate the solution of
your PD. But in practice how to enforce
that and the idea is actually very very
simple. Let me first describe it with
the heat equation and then you'll see
that the same applies to any NPD or OD
for that matter or stoastic differential
equation and so on. So what is the idea?
The idea is that let's let's again be
very very specific. So we have the heat
equation uh given here we have zero this
is just in 1D one spatial dimension and
of course temporal dimension you have 0
BC like before zero boundary conditions
and you have some initial conditions so
this is the simplest setting that you
can use the heat equation for so
remember that there is a solution u is
the solution
maybe I shouldn't be using green but u
is the solution And then I'm going to
find a neural network u theta which is
going to approximate it. Now remember
what does u map from? It takes space. So
u is a function of x space and time and
it provides a scala. Temperature is a
scalar. So it provides a scala. So in
order to approximate this u my neural
network has to provide has to be given
the same inputs and has to provide the
same output. So my neural network is
given the input x and the input t. It
provides a function u theta which
belongs to r right so it's a scala
output so it's a neural network which
has exactly the same sort of input
output relationship as your underlying
ground truth of course theta is the set
of parameters that we are going to
define these are the weights of the
network the biases of the network and so
on so now this is uh the setting and the
idea is essentially to find theta maybe
I write it here
find theta
such that u theta is close to u right so
this is the basic idea now remember that
neural networks what we can do is we can
define any value of theta weights and
biases and you get a function you get a
representation a realization of the
neural network so in particular if I
take a random we start the process with
some random values right so let's say
that theta equals to theta 0 which is
essentially random
right so what happens time. Of course,
this uh function that I'm getting is a
function. It's a function of space and
time.
Okay. It's a function of space and time.
It is of course randomly not going to
satisfy your initial conditions, right?
So, you can you can evaluate it. It's a
function of space and time. You can
evaluate it at any point. Let's say that
we evaluate it along the initial line.
So, and then we match or we see whether
it matches my initial condition or not.
And of course in general it is not going
to match your initial condition. Right?
There will be some error or a mismatch
there. Similarly on the boundaries it
has to be zero on the boundaries. But if
you take a random neural network it is
not going to be zero on the boundaries.
It will have some value on the boundary.
So these are again mismatches with what
we want. Finally what do we do about the
interior about the interior of the
space-time domain? We know that there we
don't have any information about U. So
we cannot do anything about that. But we
know that my ground truth U satisfies
the heat equation. Right? So it
satisfies the heat equation. Does this
neural network satisfy the heat
equation? How closely does it satisfy
the heat equation? So this we can
calculate because remember my u theta is
a function of x and t. So now I can so
remember that neural networks is all
about automatic differentiation back
propagation and so on. So in principle I
can calculate the gradient with respect
to time. I can calculate the gradient
with respect to space and I can evaluate
it at every single point. Right? So this
is not going to be not going to be hard.
You can do that and of course um
magically this is not going to be zero.
Right? Because there it's a neural
network. It's a random function. There's
no reason why it should satisfy the heat
equation. But we can measure it. We can
measure what is called the residual. So
this is a very this is a traditional PTE
term. So we can measure what is called
the PD residual and we can calculate it
very efficiently as you'll see using
automatic differentiation because neural
networks is all about automatic
differentiation back propagation
computing derivatives and so on. So
essentially what we can do is that for
any theta any realization of the neural
network we can compute the mismatch in
the initial conditions this guy here. So
this is the initial conditions residual
in the what is called temporal boundary.
We can compute the mismatch in the
spatial boundaries because these are
this is the mismatch in the spatial
boundaries. And finally we can also
compute what happens in the interior.
How big is the error with respect to the
PD or how badly does this uh neural
network random neural network satisfy
the PD. So we can compute all these
things right now. These are pointwise
quantities. We can compute them at any
point that we chose. Right? But of
course to define an or to define a
training objective, it is not enough to
look at pointwise quantities. We have to
integrate them. So it is quite obvious
what we need to integrate. So this
temporal domain or the temporal boundary
term is the integrated over the spatial
domain. This guy is integrated over the
boundaries and over time. And this guy
is integrated over space time. And when
you comp consider all these this j theta
is a very automatic error or mismatch
term right. So this tells us how poorly
does my or how well does my chosen
neural network approximate the residual
of the PTE how well it approximates the
initial conditions and how well it
approximates the boundary conditions.
And we want this to be zero right
because we want the solution of the PTE
to be satisfied. So we want this guy to
be zero or as close to zero as possible.
We want this guy to be as close to zero
as possible. We want this guy to be as
close to zero as possible. So the joint
residual is what we are going to
minimize, right? And if these things
were zero, if we're able to find a
global minimum which is zero, then of
course we are solving the PTE because
then there is only one unique solution
to the heat equation for instance and we
are done. Okay. So the basic
construction is very simple. Given any
random initialization value of the
neural network, you can find out the
mismatch at the boundaries and you can
find out the mismatch in terms of the
PTE and all that you want this neural
net all the training process to do the
gradient descent to do is to minimize
this error is to minimize this residual.
So is this clear? Are there any
questions here? because this is the key
crux of the of the entire argument that
we are able to do that. I'm happy to
take questions also from people on Zoom.
So
yes, go ahead.
>> You always have to specify final time.
>> No, in principle you can take infinite
time but then you'll see in a second
that uh this is impractical. Also for a
there are there are ways to there are
ways to avoid that. it's not necessary
but at the moment the problem is defined
in a in a finite time. Okay. And for the
heat equation there is exponential decay
in time. So when if you wait long enough
you'll get zero anyway. But it's it's
it's a good question. Someone on Zoom
asked me a question. Uh what is the
advantages? It's computationally
cheaper. We will talk about that. Leo
Leonard is the person who's asking.
We'll talk about what are the advantages
and what are the disadvantages uh in
today's lecture as well as tomorrow's
lecture. But at the moment everyone
understands what what is going on here.
This is what what is important. Further
questions? No. Okay. So now we have a
route right? We we know that in case we
have been able to train this neuronet
network we are able to get it down to
zero then we are done because then we
know that there's a unique solution of
the PTE and this unique solution is
going to be attained if this J J hat I
think I called it it goes to zero. But
there are some obvious issues. The first
obvious issue is that no one can
calculate integrals exactly right
because these are integrals. You cannot
just calculate them by hand. These are
complicated integrals. So you this is
impossible. So you cannot directly use
integrals. No one no one can. So
whenever you have integrals you have to
do some approximations. And usually
people have learned this in basic
numerical analysis that instead of
having this complicated integrals what
we are going to do is that we're going
to replace them by quadrice rules. Okay,
quadricure rules. So quadriure rules are
essentially ways in which you can
minimize um minimize uh integrals in
terms of quadrices right so or not
minimize replace integrals in terms of
quarteres and there are different ways
to do it. So the simplest way is uh
Monte Carlo right Monte Carlo tells you
that you can replace an integral. So if
you have an in f of z dz some integral
here you can replace it by 1 / n
summation of f of z i i i from 1 to n
and this zi is iid right this is Monte
Carlo this is well central limit theorem
essentially then you get a convergence
rate and so on and this is the simplest
thing that you can do of course many of
you have learned numerical analysis
there are much more structured ways to
do this uh quadricure we will look at
them later but the principle is the same
that by traditional numerical methods,
numerical techniques, what you can do is
that you can take each of these
integrals and replace them by quarter.
So for this particular example, what I
did is I just took random points. Uh you
can see that these are essentially
random points. So just a visualization.
So remember that I have three integrals,
right? So I have the integral that is
sitting in the interior of the domain.
One that is sitting in the boundary and
the temporal boundary the initial line
and one that is sitting on the spatial
boundary right or two the two spatial
boundaries in in this case. So what do
you do? So as you can see the blue
points are random points. So these guys
here these are random points that are
chosen in the integral of the domain.
The black points are the ones on the
boundaries and here on the initial line.
Okay. So then we can replace these loss
this big integrals by some quadriure
rules or Monte Carlo essentially which
is given by this formula here. So I have
replaced the one in the temporal
boundary by NTB points and this is your
um let's say the approximation the Monte
Carlo approximation to the quadricure.
This guy here is the Monte Carlo
approximation to the quarter at the
boundary and finally you have a similar
term in the interior. Okay. So all of
this are very obvious changes that you
can make. So you can you can just
replace it. Right? Now this quantity uh
so this is just quadriure you we use
Monte Carlo but you can use quasi Monte
Carlo Gaus Newton Gaus Newton cleans
Curtis there are all kinds of quadrice
rules that you can use but if you're
dealing with highdimensional problems a
Monte Carlo is practically the only only
way to do that. Okay so you can do that.
So now you have certainly a computable
quantity. Okay. And this computable
quantity is that you choose these
quadriure points. Uh you choose these
quadriure points and then uh just
compute this um whatever these residuals
because these can be either pointwise
evaluations of the function or you can
use automatic differentiation to compute
them. And then you have a loss function
and then you just minimize right you
have to minimize this loss function and
this can be done by Adam or whatever
LBFGS
BFGS some optimization algorithm. So let
me just summarize maybe I add a page.
How do I add a page now?
No, I don't want to.
So strange that
can anyone help me here? I just wanted
to add uh oh this this one.
Okay. So let me just summarize quickly
what we what we try to do and we
summarize at the level of an abstract PD
right because uh we can do that. So
summary
so this is essentially the pins
algorithm and we will see it again and
again and again. So, so given PD
and I do it slowly so that given PD of U
equals to F in some domain
I don't know D for instance no D is a
bad choice
omega perhaps this can be space time
okay
so what do you do and some boundary
conditions let's Say b of u equal to g
on the boundary of omega. So this can be
space time. So remember that space time
boundaries are the initial lines plus
the boundaries. Right? So this is uh so
this is your equation right? So this is
your equation.
So what do we do? How do we do the
approximation? So
given neural networks ns
u theta. Okay. So compute
interior residual or PD residual.
No, maybe I I'm sort of jumping the gun
here. Choose quadriure points.
Quadriure points.
So this could be some yi
belongs to omega and some zi belongs to
the boundary of omega. So choose some
parture points. This can be done on
whatever way you want to do. Choose a
residual interior residual rn of yi
which is given by d of u. What is should
the chosen points change in time? They
can change in time but I'm choosing over
space time. Right? So you can just
randomly get some points over space
time. You don't they can change in time.
There's there's no reason that they you
you're free to choose. You're choosing
randomly over space time. So in in
principle they are changing over time.
Right? So dd of u of theta evaluated at
yi
minus f of yi. So this is your interior
residual. then boundary residual.
So this is R perhaps of Z I. So this is
you apply the boundary operator B of U
theta of Z I minus G of Z I and then you
have the loss function.
So this is j of theta which is 1 / n i n
int maybe
i from 1 to n in
of r int
y i
can take a power p here plus nb
i from 1 to nb
of uh now I'm sort of struggling with
space
n rb B of Z I to the power P and you'll
find theta star which is R min
of J theta
by gradient descent that's it so that's
the algorithm it can be very neatly
written so given your PD given your
boundary and initial conditions choose
these quadriure points this is at your
choice but ideally random points because
they are the easiest in some sense then
compute the residuals This is automatic
differentiation. This is autodiff. It's
a very very important thing because this
has to be done efficiently. This is
autodiff. In the tutorials, this will be
emphasized even more that this is this
is an important point. Compute the
boundary residual. This is this can also
be autoative because if you have no man
boundary conditions, you have to
evaluate derivatives but generally
pointwise evaluations. Then you have
this uh loss function that you minimize,
right? And that's it. So it's a very
very simple algorithm and one of the
reasons why pins are so popular is
because they are trivial to code because
uh even you'll see that uh this is an
example this is some code that I wrote
many many years ago myself and you can
see that just to just the code led to
compute the gradient right so it's
pytorch all of you are familiar with
pytorch now after the two tutorials so
three tutorials and all that we have to
do is to compute uh gradients. So this
is one temp one time derivative, one
space derivative and when you repeat it,
you get the second space derivative and
you can compute the residue, right? It
takes a very very it's very very quick
to compute these things very easy to
compute these things and that's why
people like pins because uh you know you
take any problem that you want uh you
know the PTE you choose your neural
network of choice activation function
weights and biases and then you write
some 10 line 20 line code and you run it
right so this is why it's popular that's
why tens of thousands of papers can be
written because for every new PD every
new boundary condition every OD you can
write this you can do this you can do
this algorithm but the question is do
they work right so this is the do the
work but maybe before I even go there
are there any questions either from the
room here or from zoom about this basic
algorithm right and I repeat that on
Monday in the tutorials uh whoeverdan or
shashen is going to explain this uh
again in code any questions so far
everyone understood how this can be done
Very good. So now let's do some
examples, right? So what are what are
the do they work is the question and
this is a big question and you'll see
that there will be a qualified answer to
that. So let's take the heat equation
multiple dimensions now. So this is UT
equals to lelassian D of U. D is the D-
dimensional
dimensional.
And as you can see in this um example we
go all the way up to 100 dimensions but
people have gone up to million
dimensions even we ourselves have gone
up to thousand dimensions. So this is an
interesting thing but let's see in 1D
you start with 1D we define a MLP so
this is just an MLP nothing fancy no
convolution neural network no recurrent
neural network no transformer nothing
right so we just take an MLP we it's uh
the width is it's the same depth and the
same width uh simple thing width is 20
depth is four uh because we are going to
very very high dimensions uh we keep the
number of training points and boundary
training points was the same which is a
very large number. So 16,384
and or more 32,768
I think and this one also is a very
large number. So we do get take a lot of
points. This is simply because in 1D you
don't need so many points but in higher
dimensions you need quite a lot of
points. So what do we observe that even
up to 100 dimensions you can solve the
heat equation to acceptable error. it
takes about 2 and a half% of error. 50
it's 1 and a half% and for 1D it's you
can solve it very very very very
quickly. This is this is not an issue.
So what does this tell us that first of
all that you can solve the heat equation
with pins you do with neural networks
there is no issue doing that. Second the
error is not increasing exponentially in
dimension. Now just imagine that in 1D I
can solve it with a finite difference
scheme but already in 5D it's very
difficult to do that. Why is that? Can
anyone give me a reason why I can't use
a finite difference method in five
dimensions, let alone in 100 dimensions?
Yeah,
>> the grid points scale exponentially.
>> This grid points scale exponentially.
This is what I said, right? Just imagine
that you need I don't know 100 points in
each dimension. There's nothing, right?
So in 1D you have only 100 points and
100 actually in time you have even more
because let's say you have implicit
scheme. So you have 100 points in time.
So 100 time steps but let's say the in
1D it's 100 points in 2D it will be
10,000 right 100 * 100 in 3D it will be
a million 100 * 100 * 100 in 4D this
just becomes impractable right and in 5D
you can imagine so you can't even store
the grid so just imagine trying to do
that in 100 dimensions 100 to the^ 100
is a very very high number so you're not
going to do that even if you take 10
points in each dimension this is a very
very high number even if you take two
points in each dimension this a very
very high number but there are other
ways to do it. There are some explicit
representation formulas. This is not the
only way to do it but certainly this is
a way using neuronet networks. Yes.
>> Is there an intuitive way to see that
there is dimensionality or is it just
like
>> yeah there is an intuitive way but I
will actually even I will not prove a
theorem but I'll show you a theorem in
the next lecture why that is true but
the intuitive way is that the solution
of the heat equation is very simple. So
even if you go to 100 dimensions it the
solution is sort of smooth. It has a lot
of uh lowdimensional structure and you
can approximate it very easily. So that
is the intuitive answer. It's a very
simple uh approximation. If the solution
of the heat equation was a sum of lot of
signs which don't decay you cannot do
this you know so it's simply because it
has this structure. Go ahead.
>> So does this then only hold for the
equation or is it
>> I will show you many many examples.
Okay. So this is this is the heat
equation already. In the next line we
have not heat equations right. So again
this these were results that we obtained
many many years ago or many many 3 four
years ago. So this is Rammit Anios uh
what he did is that he took not heat
equation but remember in the very first
lecture I told you that in mathematical
finance also we have uh PDEs which come
in and for instance these are so-alled
black Scholes PDEs and uh these are not
heat equation I I don't have the exact I
think in the very first lecture I gave
you the exact form of these PDs or Hon
PDS these are not heat equation but
they're heat type equations in the sense
that black shows there is a
transformation by which you can you can
go to the heat equation not H but these
these are these are PDEs and the same
story holds right you can really solve
high dimensional problems 100 dimensions
the error is rather small here also with
100 dimensions the error is rather small
so you can really solve some very very
complicated uh complicated PDEs so there
are I think you asked this question that
is this the only only case no we have
many many examples
But I suggest that now we take a 5
minute break because today unfortunately
or fortunately I don't know you I don't
know how many of you know this but there
is this AI juric AI festival that is
going on right and that means that uh
there is some conference in Oricon that
I
okay so let's let's continue and try to
look at whether pins work for other
other problems or not and also keep on
illustrating what what it is about
what's the idea so the next example is
so so far we have focused on linear PDS
okay so these are linear PDs so a
natural question comes is can we
approximate nonlinear PDS right so if
you think of it in principle as I wrote
down here there is nothing linear about
it any PD is fine as long as we can
compute this uh residuals right and it
turns out that you can you can solve
nonlinear PTE let me give you an example
this is what is called viscous
conservation laws. So what is the PTE?
The typical example of this is a burgers
equation, but this is a larger class
than that. So the PD is given by this
relationship here. So you have U is a
scalar quantity. So it's still one one
one thing, one one object. And then you
have some nonlinear term. F of U.
There's a divergence here. So F is in
general a vector because it's in several
space dimensions. And then you have some
llashian because this this is what
models viscosity right so in one 1D this
is rather straightforward it's ut plus f
of ux equals to some new * uxx so it's a
heat equation but together with some
nonlinear transport term okay and you
have been given some initial conditions
and you can also take zero boundary
conditions as before so you repeat the
process you select random points
training points or collocation points as
these are All you can evaluate the
residual. Now all that you do is you
take your f of theta apply an f sorry
take u of theta your your neural network
your pin you apply an f to u of theta
and then you use autodiff
autodiff
a back propagation to compute dx of f of
theta. Right? So this is not uh not not
hard. It's just one one simple
iteration. So now uh again I I sort of
repeated this argument that you define
this neuronet networks on these these
particular points. You compute the
residuals in particular. This is the
interesting bit of the residual because
this is a nonlinear computation. But you
know neural networks are anyway
nonlinear objects. So autoiff back
propagation works equally well for all
these functions. And then you have these
loss functions boundary interior
uh interior here and the two boundaries.
And here I put some weights. Okay. So
these are the so-called I didn't say
that before but you can have quadrice
weights. So there can be different
quadrice rules for instance Gaus Gaus
type rules Gaus leandre or gaus lair or
whatever rules that you have and then
these are the weights of this. If it's
Monte Carlo it's the uniform weight 1 /
n right? But if it is Newton or Gaus
it's it's Newton quotes a Gaus it's
slightly different or significantly
different but you can do that and once
you do that uh you run the algorithm and
these are some results. This is the
phenomena here are going to be very very
different. So you start with an initial
condition which is given by the
sine wave here. So this is your initial
condition and the viscosity is uh one
over 100 here one over a,000 here you
and in the next lecture you'll see that
we'll go further down this route. So if
you take one over 100 or one over
thousand it doesn't matter what happens
is that in the beginning you have some
um some shape some some sine wave and
what the nonlinearity essentially the
the viscosity which is anyway small is
just diffusing things out a little bit
but what the nonlinearity does which is
the interesting bit is that it it
creates uh some compression and some
refraction. So in these parts the it
gets compressed. Okay the wave gets
compressed and away from it it gets
refracted or gets spread out. So because
of that you get this kind of kink here.
You get what is a dis almost a
discontinuity. It's still smooth because
there's some viscosity. This is a sharp
uh traveling wave or sharp transition
layer. And when viscosity is zero it
becomes what is called a shock wave.
Right? So this is uh some dynamics here.
Very very simple neural network. It's in
1D. So you can just take 256 points uh
in the boundary and in the interior it's
8,000 points the space time. Okay. So
spacetime points 8,000. So you can think
of it as 100 * 100 roughly speaking. And
the neural network is extremely simple
depth of 8 eight layers stacked on top
of each other MLPS. By the way the this
is a point that I forgot. Then all the
examples that I showed you the
activation function sigma is a
hyperbolic tangent. And can someone tell
me very quickly why can't I use relu
mean in principle I can use any
activation function right? So why do I
prefer hyperbolic tangent and not relu
yes
>> yes it's not smooth because we have to
take derivatives. So if I take ReLU then
what happens is that if you do pointwise
evaluation no problems but the moment
you start differentiating across a
discontinuous function you end up in
trouble. So one does not use relu but
you can use sort of smoothen versions of
relu jello or swigloo or whatever there
are many many smoothen versions of relu
but for simplicity in all the
experiments that we do in this context
is hyperbolic tangent so that that does
the work for us but there are other
activation functions that you can use.
So with the hyperbolic tangent you see
that the error the the total error or
the test error is going to be very very
small. It's like 1% 1.2% and so on. So
it can be done uh done in a way very
very efficiently and it captures this
complex nonlinear transitions very well.
So it's not just about linear phenomena.
Here is an example of something which is
intrinsically nonlinear. Right. So
questions about this. Yes.
>> I was wondering about the law
differentiation. Yes. So we not only use
it to compute the normal derivative for
back propagation but also for the
derivatives that appear in the PD.
>> Yes.
>> Because you know that the point about
back propagation is uh and I think it
will be emphasized in tutorial is that
you can compute derivatives with respect
to the parameters theta but you can also
compute derivatives with respect to the
input. It's a very very simple
transformation between the two. So in
general when you do when you train a
neural network what autodiff does is
that it computes the derivatives with
respect to the parameters but to compute
derivatives with respect to the network
is with the inputs to the network is
free. You know there's a very simple uh
this is the reason why this method works
because you have the same sort of
efficiency in computing the derivatives.
Okay. When it comes to higher and higher
derivatives there's an issue. I'll show
you some examples later on. But uh in
general, this is a very efficient
computation at least for the first
derivative. Okay, further questions? No.
And when you have nonlinearity, you just
apply nonlinearity to the output of your
network and you back property through
that.
Okay, let's up the ante a little bit. So
far, what you saw was multi-dimensional
linear equations, one-dimensional or
multi-dimensional nonlinear equations,
but they were scalers. Now the the
equation that is the most interesting at
least to me are the Navia Stokes
equations right because these model
fluid flow and fluids are very important
element in physics. So what are Navia
Stokes equations they are written out
here the exact form of the equations is
not important but what is important here
is now the unknowns are given by
vector a system of equations. So the
unknowns are u which is your velocity
field. This can be ux uy u z in general.
So these are the three components of the
velocity field. There's a velocity
and p is the pressure.
Okay. So this is a vetorial.
The the output has to be a vector now
not just a scalar. The input is always
uh a vector given by x and t. Right? x
has three components now x y and z.
position and then t is of course time uh
and what else the number of equations is
also four in this case because you have
the three evolution equations momentum
equations as these are called these are
given by these equations here the
details if you don't know the nav sto
equations it's not important but this
this are the equations here and then you
have a constraint the divergence uh the
flow is incompressible so which means
that the divergence the velocity field
is equal to zero you have some initial
conditions and you have what are called
no slip bound conditions. Okay, so this
is again the same process repeats
itself. There's no reason why my neural
network output has to be a scala. It can
be a vector and that's all that that
that happens here. So I I didn't put a
sort of visualization of this points
because it's difficult to visualize in
2D and 3D but the idea is exactly the
same. So now instead you have
potentially four uh inputs. This is the
three components of space and time and
you have potentially four outputs. These
are the three components of the velocity
field and the pressure field. Right? So
these are independent neural networks or
this is the output of the stable neural
network. There's choice that people can
make and then you can compute the
residuals. Again nonlinearities this is
nonlinear no problems. Uh you can
compute the divergence. Um again it's
just linear derivatives. You just
combine these and then on the quadriure
points you apply the quadrice formula.
Here again I put some weights. This
could be Monte Carlo 1 / n or these
could be some some fancy weights
depending on the quadrice rule that you
have chosen. So this this can be done.
Okay. And then the same procedure. So
now just imagine that uh if you wanted
to write a finite difference scheme for
the Navis Stokes equation is much much
harder. So if you know the finite
difference scheme for a heat equation to
go to the finite difference scheme for
an Navia Stokes equation first of all
that doesn't work but even if it works
this is quite a bit of work to teach you
that whereas with pins this is just
nothing changes you know you essentially
use the same code to compute the heat
equation slight variation and you can
compute the Navia Stokes equations right
does this work these are now harder
problems right you'll see that uh we'll
see here so this is what is called a
tail of vortex vortex. This is a very
concentrated vortex that moves with the
flow. So, it starts here and then it
moves with time here, right? And if you
approximate the pin, it does a fairly
good job. I don't remember the exact
error, but it's around 1% in this
particular case. And you can see that it
it captures the fluid motion quite well
with a concentrated vortex. It moves
quite well. Of course, there is some
error here, right? So, these are some
spurious waves that are there. Remember
that the initial data is not exact,
right? It's also approximated because we
are we have a loss term. We're not
exactly enforcing it. There are some
tricks on how to how this can be used
exactly. Uh this is a more harder
example. This is what is called a double
shear layer. We'll come to this problem
again and again and again. So these are
the initial conditions. Uh this is what
is called the voticity.
But this is not you can you can extract
the this is a curl of the velocity
field. So if you have velocity you just
apply the curl and you get the vorticity
and this is how it uh this is a ground
truth right uh so as you can see in the
beginning you have some thin layers of
vorticity they start because they're
thin layers they start sort of forming
vortices and as time progresses this
periodic boundary conditions you see a
very well-developed vortices that are
moving around right so this is the basic
construction even in this fairly
complicated problem the pin seems to
work well but not as well as four right
here this was a very good approximation
here the error is about 4% it's 3.8% but
it's about approximately 4%. in
particular you can see this very sharp
vortex here right so this this feature
here
uh I don't know how well you see it but
uh
probably well enough so this things roll
around with each other this guy is being
smoothened out the the shape is captured
but this guy is being smoothened out but
this is an approximation it's not an
exact solution it has does 4% error but
at least you can see that we're
approximating a fluid flow and we're
doing it with a few lines of code so
That's in some sense an achievement. So
we can we can do even even more. We can
go to so remember that this is second
order derivatives. So for heat equation,
a sto equation, burgers equation, these
are second order derivatives, right? So
llassian is the differential operator
that we come in. But can we go even
higher? So these are so-called
dispersipes. I don't know how well some
of you might might know this. For
instance, if you have the KDV equation,
so this is UT. Let me write it down. So
u t + u ux is equal to some new * u x.
So it involves a third derivative. Uh
and this one is benjamino. This is a
sort of and we have in the same paper we
also explored fifth order derivatives.
And this one is um some non-local
equation that's not important. But for
instance for the third derivative this
is with solitons. Uh so you can see I
don't know how well you see this. I
expand it a little bit. So this is the
initial condition in in blue is the or
is it yeah I really can't see I think
blue is the initial condition. Yeah it
has to be of course because uh so this
is one solid on here another solid on
there and then these things move this
guy moves it sort of eats this up and
comes out. This is a exactly integraable
system and you end up with this solution
and the pin is able to resolve this
without any problems. the error is 0.1%.
So this is very very very very good
result in some sense. So this tells us
that third derivatives is not a problem
because of course a back propagation
becomes more expensive. It's also an
approximation. So you would expect that
as you compute more and more and more
derivatives you'll end up with trouble
right and this can happen. Yes.
>> Is there a reason why for which treat
space and time the same?
uh you can treat them differently also
but there is no reason why we can't it's
simplicity right you can treat them
different in fact some of the earlier
versions of pins what is a good question
that you ask and some of the earlier
versions of pins what people did is that
they just used it uh they had time
stepping scheme right because in space
is where you have uh this exponential
growth because the time is just one
dimension and in a way it's a very
special dimension because the only one
that has a arrow in it, right? That is
causality in time. So what people did is
that they cut off uh spacetime into time
snapshots and then they just uh this is
like I don't or whatever time temporal
approximation and then just for the
spatial part they use spins. So this is
possible but there is uh computationally
and in terms of efficiency this is uh no
better the the
next lecture perhaps we'll cover this a
little bit but uh you can when you can
do both at the same time why not do it
means this is this is the point but it
can be done in a by treating time
separately and in a special manner yes
>> you refer to it error is it just like LP
>> L L1 in these cases But they all the LP
errors behave similarly. Okay, but it's
L1 or L2. Maybe I don't remember now,
but it's either L1 or L2. Uh in this
case, L2 makes sense because the
theorems are in L2. But uh so the point
that I wanted to illustrate here is that
you can do third derivatives. So you can
do higher dimensions, you can do
nonlinearities, you can do systems of
equations, you can do high high
derivatives. There's a whole spectrum of
phenomena that you can cover by using
this very very simple idea. Right? So
the last point that I wanted to mention
in this context is what are called
parametric PDS. So parametric PDS are
this is an example that so this is often
in engineering or physics for that
matter. What you end up is not just u
not just uh three dimensions in space
and one dimension in time but the
problems often have parametric
representations. For instance here the
initial conditions uh are a function or
not just of space but of a parameter
which is sixdimensional. If you remember
that I had this is a single solidon. So
it could be that the initial condition
let me try to recolct the initial
condition was given by some wave like
this. So this is your initial condition
but maybe the parameter was the center
of this wave the spacing in this wave
and maybe the height of this wave and so
on. So there were many different
parameters and when you change these
parameters you get a parametric PD. So
for a traditional numerical method for
each parameter you have to solve this
independently. Of course you can do it
in parallel but now the advantage of pin
is that there's no curse of
dimensionality implicitly right. So in
principle I can take my So now the
problem here depends not just on space
and time but also on parameter. So in
principle my solution u is a function of
time is a function of space is a
function of parameter y and my u theta
the neural network u theta is also a
function of spa time space and
parameter. So now it becomes a
eight-dimensional function instead of a
two-dimensional function. But as I
showed you, we solved 100 dimensional.
So what is eight dimensions? Nothing.
Right? So now you can repeat the same
process. Uh the parameter there is no
gradient with respect to the parameter.
The gradients are still with respect to
space and time as you can see. But the
parameter is just sort of sitting there.
So you can you can just take the same
sort of quadratic points and you can
compute and we just took the mean and
the variance with respect to the
parameters. it the error is very small.
It's like 0.5%.
So this parameters could be six they
could be 60dimensional and I would have
the same kind of calculation. So this is
uh the advantage now right that at one
go you can you can sort of solve this
problem. Did you understand that when
you have a parametric description the
dimension the parametric dimension can
easily be subsumed into the because
you're not even computing with
propagation. So it's it's not that
expensive either. So this is a big big
difference because uh if you had a
numerical method you solve for one
parameter take another parameter you
solve for that parameter you solve for
that parameter you can't solve for all
of them together because then it would
be a eight dimensional problem right so
this is this in this way pins are very
very fast at doing these kind of
calculations okay so so far so good so
we illustrated different kinds of
problems nonlinear linear
highdimensional low dimensional
different kinds of phenomena dispersive,
hyperbolic, parabolic and so on and
that's why pins are very popular because
take any PD you can try it out and you
can get some results right this is this
is the whole point one important point
to emphasize here and this is what I
essentially started out with is the role
of data
also people on zoom if you have any
questions you can you can answer in the
you can ask in the chat and I'll be
happy to answer so I don't want to make
you feel left out. So now what did what
did I use any data so far right? So this
is a data free approach. Of course we
use the initial data and the boundary
conditions but these are always given.
So in principle for the forward problem
mean this is what we have done so far.
Given initial conditions boundary
conditions we predict the solution at
later time or all over space. It
requires no data.
So in a way it solves the problem that
we started out with that uh okay so we
don't have data because to solve to get
data we have to solve the PTE but
objective is to solve the PD so how can
we do that so we don't need it
people have observed that if you give it
some small amounts of data means some
somehow by yes how small data like
additional term to the
>> no no yeah yes I I will explain that
I'll explain that that's a very very
good point. So if you have small data
and especially for parameterized PDEs
this is going to be very very relevant.
So let me uh since you asked this
question what happens if I have small
amounts of data. Let me try to explain
this by how do you add data to pins
right? So again I'll I'll write down
uh let's say how to add
label data
to pins
and then for inverse problems we will
see that there's a very natural way to
do that. So remember that I have my PD
so D of U.
uh so let's uh let me give you an
example with respect to paramet
parametric parametric pds so that I can
also explain the point about parametric
pds so remember that parametric pds is u
which is uh mapping from x cross y to r
so u of x forget about time for the for
simplicity here and y is your solution
is a solution
and y is the parameter.
This could be high dimensional. Okay,
this um whatever dimensions that you
want. So the pd itself could be
I don't know dx some differential
operator in x of u uh evaluated at the
points xy is equal to some f of xy. So
this could be my pd. Remember that uh
this is just uh the differential
operator for instance the llashian is
just given a function of x there is no
relevance plus boundary conditions for
for simplicity because I don't want to
write out the notation completely I'm
just ignoring boundary conditions just
assume that they are there so now what
is data so this is a PD data could be in
this case that not for every parameter
but for some parameters you have uh some
ex exact information available So data
maybe I use a different
data
could be u at x i y j is given.
So what do I mean? X I is your quarter
points, collocation points or training
points whatever you call it and YJ are
some given parameters.
Given parameters so what do I mean by
that? What it means is that either you
have a question yes we assume in the
data
>> no no here just for simplicity in
principle you can always assume noise
but for simplicity this is noise free
for instance by numerical simulations.
So what what am I saying here right?
What I'm saying here is that you have uh
the parameter space could be
one-dimensional could be multiple
dimensional for some values of my I and
J look the same but so be aware of that
right for some parameters could be 10
okay I am maybe I performed a numerical
simulation or I have some experiments in
that case measurement noise will be very
very important but let's say that I
performed a numerical simulation and I'm
able to provide you the data at those
points and I know that at every other
point the PTE holds. Okay. And then so
the XI are the collocation points in
space spatial collocation points and
then let's say Y hat
K are the parametric collocation points
because this these could be very
different from each other collocation
points. So now what how am I going to
use this data right? So this is the
important point. So now I know that the
PTE holds for all parameters and for
every point in space and boundary
conditions and so on. I also know that
for some parameters which are given by
this YJ the I have the data okay either
noise free if it's from a simulation or
noisy if it's from a measurement. So
what I can do is that I can combine the
two terms. So what I do is as as before
that you compute a residual a PD
residual.
So this this is so first of all I have
to define a neural network right how
many more colors can I use orange so
neuronet network so this will be u theta
right and this is a function of x and y
so and output is whatever scalar for
instance uh output so I have a neural
network I can define the pd residual so
this is given by d no
I used capital d so this could be
nonlinear error dx of u theta at the
points x i y k. So at all these
parametric points and so on I can define
this residual. I call this as some rpd
for instance and um yeah x i yhat k.
So this is uh the residual I can define
it and of course this is not going to be
zero for a random function but also for
the same neural network I can supervise
it with the data. So this is the data
I can also call it as a residual just
for simplicity because it's a residual
it's a mismatch right? So how do I call
it? R data
R data.
This is uh at the points X I the same
quadriure points just for simplicity.
But this one is only at the parametric
points YJ. This is uh some
I don't know
maybe I don't even have to do a norm
here. So this is u at x i
y j minus
u theta at x i y.
Okay. So this is a very very natural
term. Could I expand it? No. So I have
these uh
I have these two terms. So I have the PD
residual and I have the data residual.
Okay. Just like we had initial data and
boundary conditions. In addition, I have
some supervised data and all that I do
now is to combine them in the loss
function, right? Because so loss
function now I'm really out of space,
but let me try to see if I can squeeze
in is given by whatever quadricure
weights W hat
um I of RPD
PD sum over X I Y K. Remember that these
yhat ks are different plus the data
terms. So this is uh
uh okay
I should have prepared a slide but I
just thought that by not having a slide
you guys will understand better then I
can go slow but now I see that it's out
of space. some yhat J some other
quadriure weight of the data term R data
of X I Y to the power P and then you
could also use a lambda some scale
factor okay so there's a very natural
this is the advantage of neural networks
that you can adapt them to data very
easily if you had a finite difference
scheme you won't be able to do that well
nowadays we know how to do that but uh
in general it is not possible so what
you do in this case is that you take uh
the PD residual and just like you had
initial data and boundary conditions you
just add this supervised data okay so
that uh so that's the way you you try to
do that questions
everything is clear okay so this is uh
and we are going to iterate on this
because we also see that for inverse
problems so this is the way in which I
did this parametric PT example so this
one so this was exactly how we did but
without any supervision but in principle
you could you could potentially
supervise it. But there are one class of
problems for PTE which is the last point
that I'm going to mention which are
inverse problems where data is
essentially a part of the problem. So
you cannot avoid that. So let me try to
explain a little bit about inverse
problems quickly and see how this uh
framework that I wrote down can be
easily implemented. So here is a very
simple example. It's called a data
simulation if you want to do it in the
context of weather forecasting. But for
engineering it's often called a unique
continuation problem. So you have some
domain D just for simplicity I took a
square. Okay you have a PD you know that
the heat equation the person equation
this is satisfied all over the domain.
You have some measurements which are
given by some observation operator but
these are only in some subdomain sort of
inside the PD for some reason you don't
for instance I I'll give you a concrete
example in a minute but you don't have
any information about the boundary
conditions because if you knew the
boundary conditions then of course you
can solve a PD but now you don't have
boundary conditions the idea is that you
know the solution of the PD you can make
some measurements in the interior of the
domain on a part of the domain on a
subdomain and this is uh this D prime
here or D and then what you have to do
is to you have to extend it extend these
measurements to the whole domain by
using the fact that you have a PD okay
and these kind of inverse problems are
there many many many many times
particularly when you're trying to
measure concentrations so just imagine
that you have some fluid flow you don't
know the initial conditions the boundary
conditions but you can measure it in
some part of the river you know that it
satisfies the transport equation given
by the Navia Stokes equation ation and
then how do you extend it outside? How
do you make measurements outside? Right?
So this is a typical example of this
kind of data simulation or unit
continuation problems. So the job or the
task is to reconstruct your solution
given the data for the PTE and given
this measurements. Okay, given this data
and this could be noisy. This is not not
necessarily without noise.
And then with the pins I told you this
is straightforward because you define
the PD residual like I did at uh at your
quad richure points and you have this
data residual or data fidelity term as
some people call it and then you put
them together and weigh them right so
this is exactly what what we do. So it's
a very sort of seamless integration of
data and physics you can do that the
more or less peace meal right
straightforward no issues with that let
me give you some examples then you see
how this works in practice so the pos
equation this is just an academic toy
problem so you have um the the domains
come in later so you have the elliptic
pd llian of u= f and then you have some
some data not in the boundary okay so
this is in some subdomain let Let me
give you the precise example here. So
what is happening here? So your d is a
square the unit square and you don't
know the boundary conditions because if
you know the boundary conditions you can
solve the postform problem. We know that
it's minus llium of u = to f everywhere
here and here but I don't know the
values but what I have is measurements
on this black points. I don't know how
well you see it. These are black points
and these are on a grid essentially
right but my collocation points are
random. So this is on purpose. These two
things are different. My collocation
points are random. So what do I do? I
define a neural network u theta right
which is a function of uh space and then
I demand that it satisfies the PTE
everywhere. No boundary conditions are
needed. It satisfies a PD at these blue
points and at the black points it is uh
fitting the data. That's it. And then I
run my gradient descent. And the exact
solution which was modeled on this is
given by this. And what the pin returns
this is the inverse problem. It's it's
it's it's very very good. The solution
is very very good. Of course near the
boundary there are large errors as they
should be. The theory of this problem
tells us that there will be large errors
near the boundary. But it does a very
very good job. So as you can see
visually this is it solves this inverse
problem. Right? uh there are some errors
uh here so with different number of mesh
points and this is even with noise as
some of you asked right so without noise
you can see that the error is like it
saturates at 1% you know neural networks
it's very difficult to go below 1% there
are some tricks these days to do that
but we will not cover them at any length
but even with noisy measurements what do
I mean that I take these values at these
points and add 1% gausian noise to them
which is experimentally realistic
Then you see that as we increase the
number of grid points it sort of starts
converging towards the saturated value
of whatever 0.9 0.8%. So even with noisy
measurements you this technique works
with noisy data this technique works.
There's no issue with that. So did you
understand that? So this is a very nice
way in which you can combine data with
physics. And then there is another
example that I have a couple of more
examples and I have 10 minutes so I I
have the time. So this is a heat
equation. Let me explain this uh in in
pictures rather than with the equation.
So it satisfies the heat equation. So
this is utus uxx = 0. And what you do
here is that you don't give the initial
conditions and you don't give the
boundary conditions. Okay, this is uh
the whole point. So it's a indeterminate
problem. What you have is data. So this
is data simulation in weather
forecasting. This is very common that
you don't know the state of the weather
everywhere. you know it at some
measuring stations and from that you
have to reconstruct and you know that
these are the solutions of whatever
equations they are and then you have to
sort of reconstruct uh the the values
here and it's the same so you have
information on these uh grid points here
and then you take random points space
time so this is uh time this is space
you take random points and uh then you
just uh do this machinery right you have
the residual the PD residual on blue
points which are randomly distributed.
On the black points you you try to make
the data as small as possible and then
you see that this was the exact solution
and uh this is how the how this guy
behaves. It does a very very good job.
Of course it matches the solution
exactly when it it can be measured right
at these points. But near the boundaries
is where there is error. This is small
error. You can see the scales here but
there is some some error that is
happening as it should be mean these are
not perfect right and in terms of the
actual numbers again the errors are with
in 1D this is very very small 0.5% and
you could also solve the inverse problem
the same kind of a setup all the way to
100 dimensions and you get about 2%
error so even for the inverse problem
there is no curse of dimensionality uh
there's no way you can do this with the
traditional method but you can do it
with this which is which is brilliant.
Uh one more example there are two more
and then I finish it's Stokes equation
not Navia Stokes but Stokes Navia Stokes
is harder to do but people have done
that. Uh do I say anything interesting
here? So the interesting thing here is
that there are this 2D for instance. So
there are two variables there is u is ux
and uy and then the pressure is p. So
there are three variables and the
interesting thing is in this case my
data is only provided for the for the
velocity not for the pressure. So
remember that the Stokes equation holds
in the whole domain right. So in
particular it will hold on all the blue
points. These are randomly chosen but on
the black points which are inside this
little domain you have only been given
velocities no pressure. So the pressure
has to be determined from the
velocities. Okay. And it turns out that
you can again do that. No problems. The
pressure errors are larger because the
pressure is there's no no information on
the pressure. It has to be reconstructed
on the velocity and it does it quite
well. 3.5% error is not so bad for this
these problems. And when you look at it
from the eye, you don't see a
difference. So for instance, look at the
pressure. So this is the ground truth
and this is what the pins uh with the
inverse problems gives you. So it is
able to solve this inverse problem.
marry the data and the PD together very
effectively. So I'll finish with one
final example which is quite striking in
a way because this is very hard to do.
It's uh radiative transfer.
So whenever you have radiation like
solar radiation it satisfies this
equation. So what are the what what what
is being studied here? So this is the U
is what is called the radiative
intensity
intensity. And what is it a function of?
It's a function of time in general. It's
very fast in time. So this is it scales
according to the speed of light because
radiation is essentially light. But
let's keep it. It's a function of space.
So three-dimensional in general.
It's a function of angle. Omega I think
is the angle because you know radiation
scatters right. So you come two
different uh rays come together and they
can scatter. So you have to make sense
of the angle and this new is the
frequency
because red light is um scattered in
different way than blue light then
violet light and so on. So we know know
this from basic physics. So this in
general is a seven-dimensional problem
right because you have time you have
three dimensions in space two in angle
angle is on the sphere and one in
frequency right. So this is also a very
complicated PTE. There are it's
highdimensional. It's transport
scattering. There's also an integral
term. So it's non-local. It's not just
uh derivatives. It's also integrals. And
we could apply pins many years ago to
this problem very effectively for the
forward problem. So as you can see,
let's take the 6D problem here. So you
cannot visualize in 60. So you visualize
something in 3D, some integral, it's
called the incident radiation and
something in 1D which is called the
radial flux. These are different
integrals and it's almost exact and it
takes about an hour.
It takes an hour to solve and I had
solved this problem with finite element
methods many years ago and that took
like one day. So there's a there's a big
saving in this particular problem and
here you can even solve the inverse
problem. Okay, so inverse problem is
that you don't know the scattering the
absorption coefficient. So you're given
some incident radiation G, you have to
find the scattering coefficient and this
again you can you can do it uh in this
data data format and you get very very
good results. It's like 2.8% error in
identifying the scattering coefficient
and it takes about an hour and a half.
So this is uh quite quite satisfactory.
So what have we covered? We sort of
introduced pins. We showed that they can
deal with forward problems. They can
deal with inverse problems, linear
equations, nonlinear equations, low
dimension, high dimension, different
orders of derivatives. And it seems like
they are perfect, right? So this is sort
of the sort of the story here. But in
the next lecture, we'll look at the
other side of this. So in terms of an
algorithm, they're very simplistic.
There's no change that needs to be done
from a very simple problem to a very
complex problem. But there is a price
that we pay. So what we're going to do
in the next lecture is that we're going
to study them a bit theoretically first
to understand whether these are just
flukes, right? Whether these results
that we observed are just incidental or
whether there is something deep and
we'll find out that the story is more
complicated. Right? So that's the first
thing. So the tutorial is going to give
you a practical uh overview of pins and
next week I'll do the theory some theory
and also tell you what the problems are
and why we need alternatives and next
week because of family reasons school
holidays I'll not be in town so this
will be online the whole lecture will be
online but I will I will send you some
details about